[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
dans cette émission nous allons ouvrir
ensemble les portes de l'europe
et voici le programme avec la crise
sanitaire inédite duo coville 19
s'ensuit une crise économique majeure
quelles réponses l'union européenne
peut-elle apporter alors que la
commission a présenté ses intentions
peut-on parler d'un plan de relance vers
vraiment les 27 états membres vont t'ils
saisir l'occasion de financer leur
transition écologique
autant de questions que je poserai à mes
invités en plateau et à distance et j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
guillaume rôti vous êtes le porte parole
de la commission européenne
ici en france bienvenue à vous également
avec nous mais à distance depuis
bruxelles philippe lambert ce vous êtes
eurodéputés belges et vous co présidé au
parlement européen le groupe des verts
et c'est également à distance que deux
citoyens européens écouteront avec
attention je l'espère ce débat clos et
depuis bruxelles et nice depuis munich
à tout à l'heure pour nous faire part de
vos remarques et vos réflexions
mais avant retour sur ce plan de relance
dévoilé par la commission européenne
750 milliards d'euros pour réparer les
dommages et préparer l'avenir pour la
prochaine génération
les précisions avec alizée boissons
la somme est historique pour sortir
l'europe d'une récession sans précédent
la commission veut emprunter 750
milliards d'euros sur l'emprunt proposé
500 milliards seraient redistribués sous
forme de subventions qui ne seront pas
remboursés
le reste sera sous forme de prêt une
bouffée d'oxygène pour des pays en
difficulté financière
l'italie la pologne ou encore l'espagne
très impacté par la crise sanitaire
seront les premiers bénéficiaires du
plan mais à quelles conditions
pour donner des gages aux pays du nord
les pays bénéficiaires devront présenter
un plan d'investissement et des réformes
compatible avec les priorités de la
commission aille presente chasse
tiassalé j'ai présenté hier encore un
plan de relance pour l'europe qui est
profondément inspiré par l'idée de
durabilité compétitive et yuping windsor
et il est centré sur le green deal
européen
il investit dans la transformation
numérique il investira également dans
les systèmes de santé
tout cela dans un but précis réduire les
inégalités au sein de notre union et au
cross algérienne l'octroi des aides se
fera par tranches et sera réexaminé
chaque année pour rembourser sa dette
la commission propose de créer de
nouvelles taxes parmi les impôts qui
pourraient voir le jour une taxe
numérique mais aussi les taxes
écologiques comme la hausse des recettes
générées par le droit d'émission de co2
ou encore des mécanismes d'ajustement
carbone aux frontières
les dirigeants européens doivent se
réunir le 19 juin prochain pour débattre
de ce plan
guillaume rôti en entendant le sujet la
présidente de la commission européenne
ue celui-là van der leyen parler de
durabilité compétitive concrètement
expliqué nous c'est quoi c'est utiliser
l'argent qu'on va emprunter au nom de
l'union européenne pour investir dans
les défis qui nous sont communs et en
gros on a deux grands défis
trois grands défis en europe aujourd'hui
le premier c'est le pacte vert c'est la
lutte contre le changement climatique
donc ça c'est la notion de durabilité et
le deuxième c'est de garder l'europe
comme une zone économique compétitive
pour pouvoir continuer à réduire les
inégalités créer de la richesse et
répondre à ce troisième des filles qui
est le marché intérieur et les
distorsions la distance qui se crée
entre les différents économie européenne
entre certains pays du sud et certains
pays du nord et donc pour ça on a besoin
de compétitivité pour pouvoir créer de
la richesse et de la redistribuer et le
plan de relance qu'on a proposé sa vis
vraiment à essayer de répondre à ces
trois des fils philippe lambert tu
pourquoi selon vous la sortie de crise
elle doit être forcément basée sur la la
conversion écologique de l'europe en
quoi est elle essentielle aujourd'hui la
force et vous que leur défi climatique a
disparu que l'épuisement des ressources
que l'effondrement de la biodiversité
sont des défis qui à cause de la
pandémie ont disparu absolument pas le
dire ces défis et est déjà brûlant avant
même que la pandémie ne frappe
ils le sont encore plus aujourd'hui et
donc il est évident que si un effort
massif d'investissement public doit
avoir lieu cet effort doivent être
dirigés vers la rencontre des déficits
atteignant siècle je vois pas en quoi
est-ce que relancer l'économie qui
essentiellement à celles basées sur les
post it du ive siècle nous aiderait si
tel était l'objectif
guillaume brouqui qu'y at-il de verre
très concrètement dans ce plan de
relance
en fait l'essentiel du plan de relance
et vert c'est-à-dire l'objectif c'est
d'investir sur les infrastructures les
technologie les compétences qui vont
nous permettre de réaliser notre
ambition du pacte vert européen qui est
d'être à la nôtre une neutralité carbone
en 2050 est donc vraiment on a ce qui
est important de mentionner dans ce plan
de relance et qui va passer par le
budget européen et donc tous les canaux
de financement vert du budget européen
qui existe aujourd'hui vont pouvoir être
réutilisés dans le plan de relance est
aussi ce qu'on veut ça a été mentionné
dans le reportage on va effectivement
demandé aux états de nous proposer leur
plan de relance national c'est à dire
qu'est ce qu'ils comptent faire avec
l'argent européen
et là-dessus aura une vraie discussion à
la fois entre l'état et la commission
mais aussi entre les états membres et
tous ses autres partenaires européens
sur comment ce plan de relance contribue
aux objectifs européens et
particulièrement à l'objectif du pacte
vert philippe lambert
ce plan de relance il est suffisamment
ambitieux selon vous sur le terrain
environnemental
ça reste à démontrer et donc comme l'a
dit votre interlocuteur représentants de
la commission il présente une ambition
affichée qui est très aligné avec la
transition écologique d'économies quand
on regarde les textes qui ont été
déposés on voit que c'est beaucoup moins
claire autrement dit qu'une série
d'exigences que nous avons imposées dans
le cadre d'autres programmes européens
comme par exemple interdiction de
financer la moins d'un façon tueries
liées aux fossiles ou l'obligation qu'
aucun élément financés par ce plan ne
luisent à la transition écologique
le principe de doux nom raemdonck ne
fait pas de tort à la transition
sous-entendu le principe aussi que les
financements dégagés par ce plan soit
aligné avec la nomenclature européenne d
investissement bei
toutes ces exigences ne figure pas dans
le texte législatif
alors qui s est elle existe dans
d'autres textes législatifs et c'est ça
qui pour nous commente grège jette un
léger doute quant à la vigueur avec
laquelle la commission compte défendre
l'alignement vert du plan et donc
compter sur le parlement pour rendre
obligatoire ce qui n'est qu'une
attention dans le texte
présenté par la commission votre
vigilance philippe lamberth guillaume
rôti soyons concrets justement prenons
un exemple la pologne va être être d un
des principaux bénéficiaires de ce plan
de relance
la pologne est actuellement largement
dépendante du charbon pour produire son
électricité ce qui génère de fortes
émissions de co2 est ce que les aides
vont elles vont être conditionné à
l'abandon progressif du charbon est ce
que vous allez être en mesure d'imposer
cela par exemple à la pologne et c'est
là où il faut peut-être voir les
différents outils qui a dans le plan de
relance il ya certains outils qui sont
des outils européens ont fait ce qu'on a
fait avec le plan de relance c'est qu'on
a musclé des outils qu'on avait déjà
proposé qui était déjà existants et on a
significativement augmenté leur volume
financier et là je pense un point
important pour la pologne qui est le
fonds de transition juste où on avait
fait une proposition à 7 5 milliards
d'euros avant la crise c'était le cadre
du café dans le cadre du green deal est
là on l'a passée à 40 milliards d'euros
donc on a vraiment significativement
augmenté et je crois que pour la pologne
de mémoire c'est x 2 x 3 les fonds
qu'ils vont obtenir grâce à ce grâce à
ce fonds de transition juste et
l'objectif de ce fonds c'est exactement
ça c'est aider les régions en pologne
qui sont particulièrement dépendante du
charbon à faire les investissements qui
vont leur permettre de se réinventer et
de retrouver un autre type d'activité
économique donc là dessus il ya pas mal
doute est il seul et comme syrie jantes
ces états là notamment de la pologne
sont pour et vont dans cette direction
là là dessus ces essais comme le
mentionnait monsieur lamberth ccc c'est
un deal qui est dans le fond c'est à
dire vous ne pouvez utiliser l'argent de
ce fonds que si vous réalisez des
actions qui sont pour la transition
juste ccc le contrat on va dire du fond
avec un réel contrôle d'aer avec un réel
contrôle derrière parce qu'il ya aussi
un plan de transition juste qu'ils
devraient être fournies par la pologne
qui pourrait expliquer comment cet
argent va être dépensé et je rappelle
aussi que chaque fois qu'ils aient de
l'argent européen qui est dépensé
il ya un suivi qui est fait par la
commission il ya un suivi très attentif
qui est fait par le parlement qui est
l'autorité de contrôle de l'utilisation
du budget européen de tous ces choses là
sont contrôlés après il ya une question
qui est un peu plus ouverte et c'est ce
que mentionnait monsieur lambertz et ses
plans de relance nationaux qu'on va que
les états membres nous proposer et sur
lesquelles on va financer avec cet
argent européen
la réalisation d'investissements de
programme là dessus il ya une part plus
rendent à la discussion mais elle est
quand même assez largement encadrée elle
est encadrée par tout ce qu'on fait dans
le cadre du semestre européen toutes les
recommandations qu'on fait et la
dimension verte est très forte dans ce
semestre la est aussi encadré par les ce
qu'on appelle les plans nationaux
énergie carbone donc ce que chaque état
dit comment il va faire pour respecter
les objectifs de baisse des émissions de
co2 demande répète philippe lambert cela
conditionnalité des aides dans le cadre
de ce plan de relance l essentiel selon
vous absolument crucial et donc ce sera
une des principales batailles que mona
mènera le parlement européen j'ai envie
dit que plus les règles d'engagement
seront claires dans la législation - le
contrôle devrait être fort a priori
autrement dit aujourd'hui nous avons
hâte ex de la coke est à la fois est
assez floue dans la dans les critères et
mais le parlement au jeu en termes de
contrôle se dirait on ne peut pas avoir
les deux soit on veut garder décrite est
relativement flou quant à l'alignement
de ce plan avec la transit et le
parlement exigera un contrôle a priori
extrêmement stricte soit on s'entend
pour faire des règles strictes a priori
est alors le parlement pourra prêter se
contenter d'un rôle de contrôle a
posteriori mais c'est vrai que il y à
une méfiance au sein du parlement
européen je pense qu'au parlement
européen à la majorité est très fort en
faveur d'un alignement fort du plan avec
la transition écologique mais nous avons
la suspicion que ce c'est nettement
moins le cas au sein des états membres
autrement dit que beaucoup d'états
membres seraient très heureux d'utiliser
ce plan pourrait dès lors que le
compagnie aérienne ou leur industrie
fossiles est par ailleurs au sein de la
commission
encore aujourd'hui sylla président de la
commission a affiché une volonté
politique très forte d'engager un green
deal européen
il n'en reste pas moins que
la commission européenne en tant
qu'institution pendant 30 ans a poussé
essentiellement des réformes qu'ils
n'avaient absolument pas dans le sens de
la transition écologique et bien dans
santa mondialisation néolibérale bon
alors justement si certains décideurs ou
ong plaident pour une reprise durable
certaines industries en oeuvre plus ou
moins discrètement pour
l'assouplissement des normes
environnementales pour sauver des
emplois se justifie t'elle quelques
exemples avec alizée boissons
[Musique]
à qui profite le coronavirus
certainement en lobby industriel
c'est le constat de deux ong les
représentants des principales industries
polluantes ont profité de la crise
sanitaire pour tenter d'assouplir les
règles sociales et environnementales
parmi les secteurs les plus actifs en
europe l'énergie le transport aérien
l'automobile ou encore l'industrie
plastique qui a par exemple fait
pression pour relancer le plastique à
usage unique comme solution hygiénique
sans succès en france l'industrie
agroalimentaire a obtenu une réduction
de la distance d'épandage des pesticides
par rapport aux habitations même jeu
d'influencé du côté des organisations
patronales le medef a demandé en avril
un moratoire sur la mise en place des
règles environnementales
une demande rejetée par le gouvernement
français un pouvoir de pression toujours
plus fort qui inquiète les associations
pour lutter contre leurs pratiques les
ong demandent plus de clarté en rendant
publics les réunions entre décideurs et
représentants
enfin il plaide pour la création d'un
observatoire indépendant de la
transparence
[Musique]
philippe lambert si vous pensez qu'il
faut se désengager de ces secteurs qui
polluent quitte à laisser sur le carreau
des centaines de milliers de salariés
est ce que vous pensez vraiment que
l'emploi justifient tout parce qu'à ce
compte là
vive le tabac vive le moment non c'est
évidemment à salles aux critiques je
rappelle que l'objectif de l'économie
c'est de servir le développement humain
al'inverse donc en effet à certains
nombres de l'industrie sont appelés à se
transformer donc clairement nous sommes
dans une économie qui est encore très
loin d'être respectueuse du cadre
biophysique que nous impose la planète
et je vous rappelle que le respect de ce
cadre est une condition de survie pour
l'humanité c'est quand même de ça qu'il
s'agit
mais ce qu'on doit faire c'est être
capable de transformer notre économie
alors bien sûr pour pouvoir la
transformer il faut éviter qu'elle
s'effondre à suis bien d'accord
autrement dit on il est plus difficile
de transformer une économie moribonde
qu'une économie qui certes a pris des
coups mais encore encore des ressources
et donc l'objectif du politique
aujourd'hui ça doit être d'accompagner
cette transition c'est à dire mettre de
la pression dans le système et cette
pression est d'autant plus facile à
mettre que aujourd'hui des pans entiers
de notre économie vont dépendre du
soutien public
mais ce soutien doit être conditionnée
par la transformation autrement dit on
ne peut pas imposer aujourd'hui là à
l'instant t
l'industrie automobile est parfaitement
vrai par contre on peut l'obliger comme
condition à des aides publiques à se
transformer à une déchéance à une
cadence rapide très clairement c'est là
qu'ils allaient avoir la résistance des
actionnaires les actionnaires sont
obsédés à la maximisation du profit à
court terme mais l'investissement pour
transformer leur entreprise a exigé bête
de renoncer à des profits à court terme
pour simplement assurer la
transformation et investir dans la
transformation de leur entreprise en
temps guillaume rôti est ce que la
commission est prête justement à
accompagner la transformation de ces
secteurs où le philippe lambert sera les
du secteur automobile il ya évidemment
le secteur aérien qui est en grande
difficulté parce que la commission voilà
va imposer une transformation de ces
industries de ces secteurs ont leurs
fans
la la
la transition et la transformation de
ces secteurs elle n'est pas imposée par
la commission ou par le parlement elle
est imposée par la réalité et le fait
qu'il faut baisser les émissions et que
toutes les industries sont d'accord que
à long terme elles vont devoir changer
leur modèle
et c'est effectivement une question de
quelle est la bonne vitesse
il faut aller assez vite pour parce
qu'il ya une urgence climatique et il
faut laisser le temps aux économies et
aux et un aux industries de se
transformer nous ce qu'on propose c'est
d'essayer déjà d'organiser un peu cette
transformation de se rassembler on est
plus forts ensemble en europe et donc de
se rassembler par filière de créer
certaines initiatives qui vont permettre
à ces industries de devenir compétitive
grâce à leur transformation et je crois
que c'est ça notre grande logique et ce
en quoi en quoi très en gros on croit
pardon très fort c'est que le pacte vert
c'est à la fois une obligation mais
c'est aussi une opportunité c'est
vraiment l'opportunité pour l'europe
d'être leaders économiques dans la
durabilité compétitive conventionnelles
tout au début c'est à dire faire en
sorte que les premiers avions
électriques soit fait en europe faire en
sorte que les voitures électriques qui
fonctionnent qui soit compétitive soit
produite en europe et donc toutes les
actions législatives et le soutien
public qu'on veut mettre en oeuvre à cet
objectif là en ligne de mire philippe
lambert le couple franco allemand est à
la manoeuvre sur ce plan de relance est
ce que vous croyez en la conviction
écologique des manades macro et d'angela
merkel à leur volonté de saisir
l'occasion de financer la transition
écologique de l'europe ben écoutez sont
deux personnalités très différentes
si vous regarder l'historique de draguer
la merkel sur le plan écologique c'est
pas très brillant aguila merkel a été
pendant des années la lobbyiste en chef
de l'industrie automobile allemande
résistant à chaque étape au resserrement
des objectifs en termes de réduction
d'émissions du secteur automobile et
donc de ce point de vue là c'est pas
brillant elle a aussi résisté pendant
des années à la fermeture de l'industrie
charbonnière en allemagne je rappelle
que le plan convenu en trinquet l'arrêté
les sons et son partenaire social
démocrate consiste à sortir du charbon
tenez vous bien d'ici 2038
donc quand le plan a été décidé c'était
à vingt ans de distance donc autrement
dit le zèle écologique d'agréables
qu'elle reste absolument à démontrer
emmanuel macron par contre parle
beaucoup mais on l'entend pourquoi ces
sujets là et je compare le discours d'
emmanuel macron début de la pandémie où
il parle de résilience transition verte
etc et que je lis le titre du monde
d'hier en dix ans et parfois la
travailler plus pour produire plus j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya comme une
contradiction si vous regardez les
choses du point de vue écologique de
débats toujours est il que il va y avoir
de la place pour les négociations qui
ont déjà d'ailleurs démarré puisque ce
plan de relance il ne fait pas
l'unanimité il faut donc s attendre à un
gigantesque marchandage entre les 27 est
ce que les conditions environnementales
peuvent être un point d'achoppement et
avec le risque in fine et qu'on se
retrouve avec un plan moins ambitieux
sur le terrain environnemental guillaume
rôti en tout cas c'est c'est un des
éléments de la négociation c'est à quoi
va servir cet argent qu'on va emprunter
ensemble donc c'est essentiel que les
états membres se mettent d'accord sur
des priorités communes les priorités que
qui sont portées dans le plan
aujourd'hui par la commission c'est
celle du mandat de la commission von der
leyen après l'accord du conseil européen
et du parlement européen donc je joue le
pacte vers le numérique et le la
solidarité entre les états et la justice
sociale c'est des priorités qui ont déjà
été exprimée plusieurs fois donc je
crois pas que ça va faire un grand débat
après il faudra regarder où est le
curseur mais je pense qu'un des points
importants c'est que la transition
écologique elle est plus facile à faire
si tous les pays européens
la démarre en même temps et la font un
peu en même temps parce qu un des grands
doutes et efrain c'est de se dire si moi
je démarre plutôt je vais devenir moins
compétitif que mes voisins et donc je
vais y perdent et donc j'ai peut-être
pas forcément récupérer mes
investissements initiaux alors que si on
se dit que c'est un objectif commun et
c'est pour ça que la loi climat qu'on a
qu'on a proposé est très importante
c'est de se dire c'est un objectif
commun irréversible pour tous les états
membres
ça je pense que ça peut vraiment être un
déclencheur important et ça peut se
traduire dans ce plan de relance qui
sera discutée jeudi
monsieur lambertye est ce que vous
partagez
l'avis de guillaume route y est ce que
vous redoutez les négociations à mur à
venir autour du plan de relance avec
peut-être la crainte que les normes
environnementales finalement soit
assouplie en fait chez moi peur de cela
que de l'absence de volonté politique de
la part du conseil robien qui je
rappelle doit décider à l'unanimité
d'avoir un plan d'européens un apport de
relance européen réellement solidaire
l'unanimité n'est pas acquise on sait
qu'un certain nombre d'états membres
continuent à penser qu' il n'est pas
question de faire preuve de charité
alors qu'il s'agit pas de charité il
s'agit d'abord d'intérêt d'intérêt
commun autrement dit des dans l'intérêt
par exemple des pays bas que la zone
euro ne s'effondre pas et donc moi c'est
surtout de ce côté là que j'ai des
craintes quant aux objectifs de la
transition écologique
c'est vrai qu'ils ont beaucoup progressé
et je pense en fait que la pandémie a
plutôt améliorer le rapport de force en
faveur de la transition écologique à la
fois dans l'opinion publique mais je
dois dire aussi dans le monde de
l'entreprise autrement dit ils étaient
sans précédent par exemple que le
patronat allemand le patronat français
patronat italien se prononcer
explicitement pour que le green deal
européen soit aucun du plan de relance
ça je crois que c'est un motif plutôt en
compte ceci étant il est bien gentil de
parler de neutralité carbone en 2050
pour rappel que le chèque nous dit que
tout va dépendre de notre action dans
les dix ans qui viennent pas dans les 30
ans qui viennent
autrement dit ce qui compte c'est le
degré d'ambition que nous avons pour
et là la bataille reste à faire
autrement dit l'union européenne elle
s'est fixé des objectifs qui si il était
étendu à tout le monde nous amènerait un
réchauffement climatique de l'ordre de 4
ou 5 degrés alors qu'on doit faire entre
albi et 2 est donc là il va falloir
resserrer atys considérablement et là je
ne suis pas sûr que nous ayons les
majorités nécessaires à l'achat en
groupe on entend l'urgence ce seront les
mots de la fin avec vous messieurs merci
philippe lambert
merci guillaume type d'avoir répondu à
mes questions on passe maintenant à
notre séquence citoyenne
[Musique]
deux citoyens européens engagés qui ont
suivi le débat et qui vont nous faire
partager leurs réflexions leurs
remarques et aussi leur quotidien plutôt
écolo clos et miquelon et jack vous êtes
belge vous avez 26 ans et vous êtes
engagé puisque vous travaillez avec des
associations autour de l'économie
circulaire
et puis depuis munich en allemagne nils
parnes vous avez 39 ans vous êtes
entrepreneur dans l'énergie et plus
particulièrement dans le chauffage
propre chloé peut-être on va démarrer
avec vous je voulais savoir qu'avez vous
retenu de cet échange entre eux philippe
lambert c'est guillaume rôti
je pense que ce que j'ai retenu
principalement c'est que la situation
actuelle on peut l'avoir commune entre
guillemets bien sûr mais une réelle
opportunité de relancer l'économie d'une
façon différente
pendant des années on avait des
industries qui surtout ici à bruxelles
on peut dire c'est entre guillemets
surpuissance au niveau de l'influencé
qu'elle exerce sur les institutions
publiques et en fait aujourd'hui on a
une possibilité de les inciter on va
dire à à devenir plus verte à devenir
plus ambitieux en termes de climat et
d'environnement et c'est vraiment
historique on a quasi jamais eu cette
opportunité avant et on a comme disait
philippe lambert ce l'impression que la
commission est passée encline à aller
dans cette direction là après voilà
c'est une institution qui depuis des
années des années n'a pas forcément été
très verte n'a pas forcément été très
ambitieux en termes de climat et
d'environnement donc je pense que ce
qu'il faut retenir france qu'est ce que
moi je retiens c'est que c'est un peu à
prendre avec des pincettes et faut être
que nous disent en anglais pour chelsea
obsèques
nils on l'a vu durant cette émission il
là il ya de la part de certaines
industries une entreprise de lobbying un
pur à 100 assouplir certaines
contraintes environnementales pour
sauver des emplois
faut-il sauver des emplois à tout prix
pendant les années à venir
nous on a toujours réfléchi
est ce que notre produit fait 10 ans on
parle on est orientée par essence et
après on rien été le profit mais aussi
on remarque qu'il ya des intérêts à des
lobbys
ceux qui sont récurrents qui bloquent
des innovations parce que bien sûr mais
on a peur de pertes et des exemples loi
mais par exemple nils est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut encore investir
quitte à transformer le secteur aérien
particulièrement en allemagne on a vu
que lufthansa résume cran est de l'état
parce que 9 milliards d'euros
si on regarde le personnel sanitaire
4 c'était même pas un petit milliard
donc si on va aller les faits c'est pas
c'est pas juste que cette heure assez
important qui a sauvé beaucoup de vide
les derniers mois qui a vraiment
travaillé comme des fous étaient traités
avec ça suffit si on clame le nombreux
pour lufthansa
par contre je vois c'est très très
lobbystes c'est pas forcément ni tard et
qui va aider des innovations c'est à mon
avis juste pour d'avoir régulièrement
allemand 9 me à bord europa contre je ne
sais pas si ça vaut la peine à la fin on
entend votre scepticisme nice chloé est
ce que vous dans votre quotidien vous
êtes prêts à avoir plus de contraintes
plus de réglementation au quotidien au
nom de la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
et pourquoi pas par exemple est bien
plus d'avions je pense que plus d'avions
s'est un peu radical parce que enfin moi
en tout cas je vois rarement les
problèmes comme blanc noir et fonds
publics dans énormément de pays qui du
monde l'économie et qui est
exclusivement dépendante du tourisme et
donc ce serait un peu je pense égoïste
de notre part de nous mixi dans taux
privilégiés qu'on puisse dire si on veut
plus prendre l'avion alors que toutes
ses économies se sont toutes ses
économies de ces pays là se sont
construites sur nos voyages
donc ça je pense que c'est peut-être un
peu radicale par contre clairement
diminué les voyages en avion ne plus
partir avec des vols low cost pour un
week end à droite à gauche
je pense que c'est essentiel si l'on
veut atteindre la neutralité carbone et
il faut être peut-être près du cou a
laissé entre guillemets mourir certaines
industries qui de toute façon ne sont
pas compatibles avec l'accord de paris
et ne sont pas incompatibles avec les
objectifs de notre qualité carbone est
ce que ça va nous apporter quelque chose
de pouvoir toujours voyagé à l'autre du
monde si c'est pour voir des paysages
qui simplement absolument dévastée par
le changement climatique des populations
qui vont mourir de faim ou qui vont être
en perpétuelle migration voilà moi
j'suis pas sûr je pense qu'il faut
réapprendre à aimer ce qu'on a autour de
soi et puis voyage et de temps en temps
mais moins mais différemment
nils concrètement dans votre quotidien
vous seriez prêt à quoi a changé quoi au
nom de l'environnement de défi le plus
grand qu'on a c'est le changement
climatique donc comme c'est pas corona
c'est pas le nazisme c'est vraiment ça
c'est pas sexy je sais jusqu'au le
moment où c'est trop tard là ça viendra
le plus intéressant d'échanger notre
manière de se comporter il faut
absolument réduire la température de
moins que des entrepreneurs dans le
domaine de l'énergie et que vous
développez justement du chauffage propre
saas etc pour votre travail et dans
votre quotidien de tous les jours qu est
ce que vous faites moi déjà je suis très
régional ça veut dire je cherche des
produits et des partenaires locales en
action ici et pas en chine ça m'ouvre
aider vraiment beaucoup en même en
énormément on est on est on était
capable de continuer de travailler et
aussi peut-être de passer des vacances
aussi local il faut pas toujours acheter
une bille et à 30 euros renner pour
aller à majorque à ça je me déjà demandé
tout le temps comment ça se frictionne
et je reste là c était ça fait très bien
ici en bavière
c'est déjà pas mal chloé vous attendez
quoi en la matière de l'union européenne
je pense que c'est essentiel que ça
vienne de l'union européenne parce qu'on
est le premier marché économique au
monde et donc on a un poids énorme sur
la scène internationale je pense
qu'aujourd'hui une énorme opportunité
encore une fois est par exemple on voit
la présidence du conseil européen a
déclaré vouloir se re lancer directement
dans la négociation par exemple du
traité avec le mercosur en amérique du
sud
et ça c'est juste pas possible quand on
est on est à un moment où on parle de
neutralité carbone on parle de relance
verte
mais on parle aussi de re signer un
traité commercial avec une zone qui
aujourd'hui enfin je pense au brésil
pardon benson c'est vraiment un pays
mais qui aujourd'hui ne remplit
absolument pas les conditions
nécessaires en termes d'environnement de
changement climatique
donc déjà par exemple c'est un
possibilités d'action pour la commission
européenne qui est très très concrètes
en tout cas il faudra compter avec la
vigie citoyenne et et on l'entend vous
écoutant tous les deux merci de vos
témoignages c'est la fin de cette
émission vous pouvez la voir et la
revoir en replay sur notre site
publicsenat.fr mais également sur
l'antenne de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures européennes
[Musique]